[音楽]
ありがとうございます何もしてないのに
拍手が起こってめちゃくちゃやりやすい
環境ですねどうもありがとうございます
改めてここから少しの時間をお借りして私
高い夜ちょっと簡単なパフォーマンスをお
届けしていきたいなと思います
改めて苗木にたかと申しますどうぞ
よろしくお願いします
ありがとうございます
ちょっとパフォーマンスを送りにするに
あたり1つ準備があります1分間だけ時間
をください
[音楽]
OKです準備ができましたこの1分間が
ちょっと後で大事な意味を持ってきますん
で楽しみにしててくださいそれでは
ちょっと簡単にパフォーマンスをスタート
していきたいと思いますどうぞよろしくお
願いします
使うのがこちらの毒です
[音楽]
すいません皆さん大体いつものここで
拍手が起こるんですよありますちょっと
わかりにくかったと思うんでタイミングを
作っていきます
拍手のタイミング僕の321の合図で全員
で改めてご協力くださいそれではいきます
8とタイミングはまもなく
3215ここでお願いしますありがとう
ございますちょっと説明しながら参り
ましょうこちら一時期テレビや
YouTube
多くのメディアで取り上げられました
水晶玉を使ったパフォーマンスです
糸や仕掛けは一切ありません
目の錯覚を使って浮かせてます
トリックアートと同じです
トリックアートと同じで
正面が一番浮いて見えるようにできてます
ねはっきり言って横その位置からですと
ちょく見え
ちゃいけないものが見えるんですよただ
一番見てみると正面だから僕の方から正面
回っていきますいきます
接客だからテレビでもYouTubeでは
ない生の世界近くで見ていってください3
人1号
ああるよしあいいですねこの左から右に
流れてくる感じがめちゃくちゃ嬉しいです
あありがとうございますあいいですね
じゃあもうどんどん行きましょうこっから
完全に正面限定です
正面限定です3215
あ
伝わりますかこの難しさ分かりました
じゃあもう時間もないんで一気に行きます
一番浮いてみるやつよでそこで皆さんにお
願いがあります一番
浮いてみるのにあるんで皆さんもうハッチ
は完璧なんですよただ若干のあの時代が気
になるんですだから
浮いて見たら全員でおーでご協力いただけ
ますか
集団無視ですか
全員でお願いしますね浮いたらおー浮い
たらOです確認します浮いたら
完璧ですじゃあ全員でいきます浮いたら大
まで間もなく
321ここでお願いします
完璧ですありがとうございますただ
正直言ってこのテロXという環境
僕がお届けしたいのはあくまでも
パフォーマンスではないんです
僕がお届けしたいのはあくまでもテトXの
テーマである広める価値のあるアイデア
です
すなわち僕の場合の広める価値の
アイディアがこちらです
新たな挑戦に必要なもの今日はちょっと
これをテーマにしてお話ししていきたいな
と思っています
僕は中学2年生の時にこのパフォーマンス
と出会いましたで最初始める時ってどう
やって始めたらいいのかなっていうところ
がちょっとわからなくて難しかったところ
なんですだからそういうところも踏まえて
お話ししてきたらいいなと思っています
ただこのお話はあくまでもパフォーマンに
限った話ではありません何か
趣味を仕事にしたいなという人らとか
会社を起こしてみようかなっていう人だっ
たりとか
会社ほど大きなものじゃなくても大丈夫
です何か新しい事業をやってみようかなと
いう人だとかまあその他夢を持つ全ての人
にお届けできたらなと思っています改めて
ここから先大道芸人たか改め私1人の人間
として中村高さがに僕の思いをお伝えして
いきたいなと思っています改めてどうぞ
よろしくお願いします
ありがとうございます
ではまずは
僕がパフォーマーになるまでの経緯からお
話ししましょうこちら
はいかわいいですよね
なんだろうこんな感じ
僕が生まれたのは平成11年の11月11
日この位置が6個並ぶ奇跡の日に生まれ
ました
奇跡の子です
札幌生まれですずっと札幌生まれ札幌育ち
どこに渡らずっと札幌止まりですただ
生まれてすぐに母親父親は離婚してました
僕は父親の顔を知りませんただそれを卑下
するようなことは決してありませんでした
母からの愛を目いっぱいに向けてそれなり
に楽しい生活だったしそれなりに幸せだっ
たなって思いますただそのまま成長を続け
て僕は小学5年生になりましたそんなある
日僕はもうこのことしか考えられなくなり
ました1つの思いに全身の語られました
その思いがこちら
うんモテたい
寝ても覚めてもこの学校の授業中でも常に
どうしたらモテることができるだろうか
そればかりをずっと考えてたんですね
当時小学5年生の頭にして導き出した
僕の考える
モテるための方法それがこちらでした
唯一無二の特別な存在になること
なかなかなんか
真理をついてますよね
他の人が持っていない特別な能力を持つ
こう特別な存在に人は憧れるんじゃないか
なみんなと同じじゃダメだなと思ったわけ
ですじゃあ
僕は何のすごい人になったらいいんだろう
考えました何がいいかな
スポーツかな
芸術かな音楽かな
いやでも今更始めてもなんかありきたりだ
なもうちょっとなんかマイナーなところを
攻めてみようじゃあ何がいいだろうか
考えまくって考えまくって
悩み続けたある日僕はとある1人の青年の
動画をYouTubeで見ましたその動画
の中ではちょうど今の僕くらい今僕二十歳
なんですけどそれぐらいの年齢の青年が
華麗に
ヨーヨーを操ってたんですいやこの容量
めちゃくちゃかっこいいなどうやらその
映像は世界大会の映像なんです
妖々って世界大会があるんだこれなら
マイナーだし唯一無二にマイナーな存在で
トップになれるんじゃないかなこの
ヨーヨーこそが俺が探し求めていた唯一
無二の特別な存在であると気づいたわけ
ですこれが僕とヨーヨーとの出会いでした
すぐに僕は近くのおもちゃ屋さんに
駆け込んで500円の小さなヨーヨーを
買いに行きました
でもこれまた難しいんですはじめ一振り目
こんな感じです
うん全然まっすぐ回らないんですね
すぐこうなっちゃうのこれ難しいなでも
ちょっとせっかくだからたったし挑戦して
みようめちゃくちゃ練習を続けて続けて
どんどんどんどんいろんな技ができるよう
になっていったんです最初はできなかった
技もどんどんとあっありますそうそうそう
拍手はねめちゃくちゃもらえるし
めちゃくちゃいろんな技ができるように
なったんですけどこれまたびっくり全然
モテなかったんですね
そうでもねせっかくこの
練習して2年間かけてできるようになった
技を誰かに見せたいなとも思ってたんです
いやでもなんかそういう機会もいまいち
ないしなと思ってたんですよねそんな要領
との出会いでした
そんなある日中学2年生から3年生に進級
したある日
僕にとある天気が訪れますそれは母による
ものでした
それまで女で一つで僕のことを育ててくれ
た母が
病に倒れました精神的なそして身体的な
仕事を続けられなくなりつまり僕の家庭の
収入は完全に
ゼロになりました
頼れる親戚の関係などもありませんどうし
たらいいんだろう何か中学生とはいえ僕
自身に役に立てることはないだろうかでも
中学生ってバイトができないんですよ
僕にあるのは
ヨーヨーだけなんです
わかったこのヨーヨーでお金が稼げるん
じゃないのこれが僕がパフォーマーになっ
たきっかけなんです今僕の同い年とかまあ
同年代ぐらいのパフォーマー仲間が
たくさんいますそんないろんな
パフォーマーのパフォーマーになった動機
を聞いてみるとだいたいみんなこう
自分の
技を
世界に届けたいだとかあの世界を笑顔にし
たいとかそういう素敵な夢を持つんです
けど僕にとっての動機は単純でこれがお金
だったんですよね
ただ
始めたばかりの未熟な僕に立てるステージ
なんかどこにも最初なくてどうしたらいい
だろう
わかった最初はお金が稼げなくてもいい
ボランティアでいいから人前に立つ経験を
積もうそう思って僕は地元の児童会館とか
病院とかに
電話をかけましたもしもし私
ヨーヨーを使ったパフォーマンスをお届け
しておりますタカと申しますがそちらの
施設でボランティアで結構です
パフォーマンスする機会をいただけない
でしょうかって言った具合に
これ行動力めちゃくちゃすごいですよね
中学3年生です多分その当時の行動力今の
僕にありませんその
当時も
きっとこれからもこの行動力っていうのが
大事になるんじゃないかなと思います
びっくりすることにその時生きたのは
ヨーヨーをひたすら練習して学んだ技術力
よりも行動力だったわけです
始めたばかりの時ってでもこういう風に僕
はおしゃべりしてなかったんです
始めたばかりの時は
ひたすらかっこいい音楽を流して
ひたすらかっこいい
技を
ひたすら難しい技を繰り返していくそんな
パフォーマンスでした
それって今考えてみればとてもとても
独りよがりなものなんですかっこいい音楽
に乗せてかっこいい技をひたすら繰り返す
これってエンターテイメントには欠けて
いるものだったと今では思います
必要なのは容量を扱う技術だとかそういう
ところじゃないなって気づいたんです必要
なのは技術力の他に何かある僕はヨーヨー
のパフォーマーであり競技者ではない競技
者からパフォーマになり変わる必要がある
じゃあ技術力の他に必要なものは何なのか
これを悩んでいる結果僕はとある先輩の
パフォーマードでやりましたその
パフォーマー
驚くことに
僕が今まで
用意をされていたステージの上で
パフォーマンスをしていたのに対して何も
用意されていないただの
路上の上
ロープを引かれたその空間の中で
パフォーマンスを届けていたんです
これを後に大道芸という呼ぶことを知り
ます
ステージがないなら自分で作ってしまえば
いいこれが結構大きな衝撃だったんですね
この大道芸
選出上
特に告知とかがされてるわけではありませ
んよってお客さんも初めは0人ですその中
からお客さんを集める必要があり視界を
する必要があり音響とかも自分で準備を
する必要があるんです
これって一言に言えば
演出だなと思うんですトークも演出のうち
この演出という言葉何も省の中に限った話
ではありません例えば分かりやすい例を元
にお話しましょうこんな感じ音楽の
アーティストを想像してください始めた
ばかりのアーティスト何も事務所に所属し
ていない無所属のアーティストこれに対し
て無名でもいいんです何か
事務所に所属しているアーティスト
皆さんはどちらの方がより
凄そうに見えるより
信頼できると感じるでしょうかな大多数の
方は事務所に所属している方をより信頼
できると考えるはずですこれもし僕が音楽
を始めるなら
きっと
自分で個人事務所を立ててそこに所属して
いるって名乗ると思うんです
これって
練習とはまた別のちょっと頭を使えば
できる
自分の価値を高める行為ですよねこれを僕
は
ブランディングと呼んでいます自分の価値
を高める演出がブランディングであるこれ
をじゃあ1回話を戻して僕の場合に
置き換えましょう僕が大道芸を始めた直後
に行った中学3年生の時に行った
ブランディングがこちら
ホームページを作って名刺を作って
新聞各社に投稿して
芸名というのはちょっとまたお話ししよう
と思うんですがパンフレットを作ってま
結構ありきたりでまあなんか
誰でも思いつくようなことだと思うんです
けどこれを中学3年生自分1人の力でやる
のって結構なハードルだったんですよねで
もこれをやってるかやってないかで全然
ブランド力が変わってきますでまぁ
ちょっと後にしたこの芸名なんですけど
僕の周りま特に札幌に限って言えば
パフォーマーなんとかパフォーマーなんと
かっていう名前のパフォーマーばかりだっ
たんですこれあえて大道芸人たかっていう
名前にしてみようと思ったんです動機は
簡単ですパフォーマーと検索しても僕は
一番上には出てきません大道芸と検索する
と僕だけが一番上に出てくるんです
初めて1ヶ月なのに
これってちょっとした工夫だけどこの違い
で
仕事の入り方が全然違うんですよね
ちょっと頭を使うだけで全然実力が伴って
なくてもとりあえずお仕事には繋がるん
ですハリボテとはいえでこれ大事なのは
始めたてだとしてもできるということこれ
らは全て少しのお金と労力さえかければ
始めたてでも僕みたいに初めて1ヶ月でも
誰でもできることなんですかかっとお金は
言うて1万円から2万円ぐらいでしょう
時間をかけてひたすら練習した技術力の
向上ということよりもより
早くより効率的にたくさんの仕事を得る
ことができました
でもハリボテとはいえこのブランディング
にはちょっとした効果がありましたあ
結果論ではあるんですがブランディングに
よって自分の
価値をより高めることができますすごく
見せることができますたくさんのお仕事が
舞い込んできますそれと同時に
自分自身もいや俺って天才じゃね
めちゃくちゃすごいんじゃねって思い込む
かなんかできるんです思い込みって
初めにお話した大前提である行動力に
つながるんですよね
自分ならできるはずだと考えるとたくさん
行動できました行動すればするほど
チャンスが舞い込んできました
チャンスが舞い込んで来れば
絶対にそれはその場所に見合った実力を
伴わなければならない
頑張ろう結果は必ず後からついてくるはず
です
そしてもう一つ
ただひたすらブランド力を上げる自分が
すごい人であると投げ切ることはあまり僕
はお勧めしません
少しの
弱さを見せることが大事だなと僕は思って
います
少しの弱さを見せることによって
応援したくなる親近感が湧くわけですね
この親近感弱さという部分を僕は
初めのショーの中にちょっとだけ織り交ぜ
てましたここで最初の1分間が生きてき
ます最初の1分間僕はこのスライドを作っ
ていました
当日の雰囲気をここに打ち込むこの会場の
雰囲気をパソコンに打ち込んでいました
例えばこんな感じ
テトメックスという環境田口先生の知的で
素敵なお話の後の登壇直後の登壇この環境
に見合ったトークがあったわけです
具体的には
この素敵な雰囲気めちゃくちゃ厳正な感じ
の雰囲気この中でひたすら喋ってあんなお
ふざけっぽいパフォーマンスをするので
ちょっとハードルですよねだからこそ僕は
あえて始めめちゃくちゃかっこいい音楽に
乗せてわざわざメガネなんかを外したりし
てかっこつけて水晶を触ってましたその
直後急に音楽が止まりますいつもならここ
で拍手が起こるんですよ
弱さですよねこの弱さって曲を止めるのも
一つのスイッチです雰囲気の落差を作って
みたわけですよね
雰囲気を自分のものに作り変えると同時に
弱さを演出していたわけですさらにお客
さんとの距離感を縮めるきっかけになり
ましたこれが弱さの部分の効果です
さらにもう一つ
お
客さんの中に子供が少ないちょっと声が
出しにくそうだな
結構僕動物園とか遊園地とかでショーを
することも多いんですお子さんが多いので
結構盛り上がりますお子さん全然いないん
でいやちょっとおーとかいう声で出し
にくいのかなと思ったんですよねじゃあ
あえて滑ってみようと思いました
浮いたらおー浮いたらおでご協力いただき
ますでしょうか
これって多分
浮いたら王でご協力いただけますでしょう
かって言ったら拍手起きたんですあえて
浮いたらOでご協力いただけますでしょう
か
削除しにくい言い方をしてみました
集団無視ですかっていうトーク言ってた
わけですよねこれもちょっとした雰囲気の
落差です弱さを見せてみましたこの雰囲気
だからこそ出来上がるこのトークこの弱さ
の演出があったわけですここでちょっと
伏線を回収していきますよこれが
空間作りつまり
狭間を作っていくはい
テーマを回収したところで次に行きたいと
思います
最後になりますが
新しい挑戦をするのに大前提として行動力
が必要ですそして
自分を
価値を高めるブランディングをしましょう
ブランディングで自分自身の自信にも
つなげますそして自分の行動がどのような
結果をもたらすのかこの
狭間を
意識してイメージしてみるわけですそして
最後に弱さを見せることもためらわず信頼
できる
助け合える仲間を見つけるといいかなと
思います
長い時間になりましたが
まここで今
多分ここに来ている人ってみんな何か夢を
持ってる人だと思いますそんな夢を持って
いる皆さんとまたどこかでお会いできたら
嬉しいなと思っています以上大道にいた
から改めて中村貴之はどうもありがとう
ございました
[拍手]